on s'en va l'autre bout là bas
carrément lundi matin cité de la santé à
laval allô
docteurs m'ont timmy nous plonge au
coeur de la salle d'urgence le taux
d'occupation dépasse les 120 % un
problème plombe les efforts des
soignants une cinquantaine de patients
occupera au lit sans avoir besoin de
soins ces patients connu sous l'acronyme
et nsa pour niveau de soins alternatifs
attendent une place en ch et celle des
coûts des soins à domicile et c'est
essentiel de désengorger nos structures
parce que c'est en les désengorgeant
qu'on peut consacrer le temps nécessaire
aux patients le temps dont ils ont
besoin pour être soigné les patients est
naissant utilise plus de 2000 places en
milieu hospitalier à l'échelle du québec
leur proportion atteint des sommets
inégalés depuis le début de la pandémie
à 13 % des hospitalisations bien au delà
de la cible de 8 % établi par le
ministère de la santé on a des enjeux
peau à naître des passions dans certains
endroits parce qu'il faut attendre que
la claque aux villes soit terminé on a
des vacances qui on à la pénurie de
personnel ça nous a amené le des enjeux
que on a moins accès à certains des au
niveau de l'hébergement parmi les
régions les plus touchées l'estrie trône
au sommet avec un lit sur cinq est
occupé par un patient et nsa à 20% c'est
un peu intenable la liste d'attentes
pour une place en ch et celle des en
estrie a presque doublé depuis 2000 18
pour atteindre environ 400 personnes par
exemple certains vont attendre un siège
à celle d un peu général d'autres vont
attendre une unité spécialisée dans son
sillage celle d et peuvent attendre des
semaines voire plusieurs mois mais de
nouvelles solutions émergent au 6 de
laval 2-2
on a
des réunions quotidiennes servent à
décider quels patients sortir en
priorité à l'aide d'un tableau de bord
créé de toutes pièces gdch et celle des
qui sont en éclosion le faisceau si ça
va peut-être jouer sur les patients qui
sont nso imaginez-vous que 2 mai matin
chacun des hôpitaux du québec réussit à
sortir ces jeux là il n'y a plus d'enjeu
de place ça fait quand même un petit
bout de temps je pense qu'on est en
attente du mécanisme d'accès à
labergement une classe en sièges c'est
l'idée depuis le 29 juin sur l'unité
réservé aux patients médicalement stable
un nouveau poste a été créé pour
débloquer les goulots d'étranglement
même vous votre rôle c'est de les sortir
les patients ces deux voies ou leproux
est le problème pourquoi ils sont pas
capables de sartène si elles tirent les
ficelles pour accélérer les transferts
elle favorise surtout le retour à
domicile pour éviter de surcharger les
ressources en hébergement
la sortie
vous êtes content
ici jean phlippe use radio-canada laval